the Joe Rogan experience if somebody
saying something go in and say no you
know the word you don't just start
throwing around these words there's
nothing anything to do with the topic
they're just that's the way they express
them so it's like the way people
disagree about things can change like
the way they communicate their
disagreement can change how it gets
resolved you know and but what always
happens is if you go hard they go hard
back and I think we're dealing with that
back and forth in this country and what
I was gonna say is about this walk far
out of March for our lives March for our
lives is that what I'm seeing that's
very confusing to me is from people who
are gun supporters like the NRA
supporters who and some of them have
even mocked these kids for getting
attention by going to these marches and
stuff like that and they're saying that
nobody would have heard of you or nobody
to know who you are like this is a
ridiculous way to look at it they it's
very defensive because if they're
feeling like someone's coming after
their guns so they're they're going on
the attack in some ways that's just
really not recommended like the way
they're doing they're basically you know
mark they're mocking what the what the
reason would be for these kids to be on
TV that got shot at these kids they've
got shot at and they're [ __ ] 16 years
old and they're gonna be on TV and
someone's mocking no would know who you
were if it wasn't for this thing like
yeah of course but they went through
that [ __ ] thing they're the few kids
that have gone through this thing in the
country that are standing on the public
stage and saying look at us you got to
do something you can't have the same
[ __ ] happen over and over and over again
and maybe they don't have the most
complicated solution but they're right
and they're there's they're forcing
people to talk and if anybody should be
forcing people to talk it's the kids
that were around their friends that got
shot who realized their [ __ ] parents
are working all day and they come home
tired and no one's gonna fix nothing no
one has the time and the negotiations
are all in bed
with the NRA and all these different
organizations if they're on the left and
everybody's hold into their special
interest groups so these kids are seeing
all this [ __ ] and they know nothing's
gonna happen
nothing's gonna happen more kids are
gonna get shot more kids are gonna get
shot and then what are the NRA people do
they they mock these kids that's crazy
at what point doesn't someone pull you
aside and goes I picture I don't believe
in violence obviously in relationships
but in the old movies when somebody was
at that stop
that's like right yes full disdain for
any retaliation trying to hit someone
with the best part you know you hit
someone the back your hand it's the back
your hand is generally more sensitive
it's like it's all it hurts like if you
hit some in the back hand you can hurt
your hand
like I know a lot of guys have broken
their hands in a fight because they hit
someone with a spinning back fist with
the back of their hand it's not
protected so that's just letting some
blow I'm so an you see we were just
saying how to beep more peaceful I'm
what I'm saying is when somebody it
doesn't even mean we're not I'm not
saying don't have a conversation and
don't disagree of course I'm us we're
saying the person that wants to shake
you and stop you is once you start
making fun of these kids someone even
that agrees with you that there
shouldn't be any isn't there's someone
on that side they can go stop and I
guess there are but when when they say
you know you should learn see Rick Rick
Rick what's his name Rick the the guy
who said if they the kids should instead
of looking for someone else to solve
their problems
they should learn CPR Rick Santorum yeah
that makes you not like that doesn't
even make sense he actually said that
nobody make sense doctors were tweeting
it brilliantly like you know like that's
like so you're saying John Lennon would
that be alive if Yoko Ono knew CPR that
say just got to use CPR to repair that
blown out liver and they explained that
to him but then you know you talk about
combating kids I thought that was a
great way just some really clean tweets
from doctors breaking it down very
cleanly this would not doesn't make any
sense harm is a Republican uh-huh so
they exhume so that's but if I just stop
me just say one thing I really feel like
is really important to this I think both
the people on the right and the people
the Left have way more in common than
they then they have a part and I think
that a lot of the the battle the people
on the Left have ziz they've chosen to
be on the left the same people on the
right they've chosen to be on the right
so anything that happens on the left
they completely disagree with they
immediately go that's a left-wing
liberal idea and they just have these
little back-and-forth with each other
that are completely unnecessary I think
the majority of people just want
everybody to get along not have crime
[Applause]